sa grande travail pour préparer tout ça
on n'est plus à un mois près pour la
livraison non à londres a terminé au
printemps
c'est depuis le xviiie siècle le lieu de
rencontre des habitants du village une
grande fontaine à cologne qui fait
aujourd'hui encore la fierté des 280
habitants de serre mange
et pourtant à y regarder de plus près
elle penche un jour à droite l'autre à
gauche c'était fontaine et quand même
s'il nage et sous les mains et mène un
mouvement parce que les sous l'assise
solide et dr gilles de gonflante que
selon la tenait à un os d'énergie et
raymond thé descendants fin oui
depuis quelques semaines des travaux de
consolidation dont commencé pour ancrer
le monument dans la terre ferme
un chantier long délicat et coûteuse qui
n'aurait pas été possible sans la
mission berne pour le patrimoine
je vais 10 à 2 en mai et lui maintient
faut être culotté dans la vie on va
écrire à monsieur berne et on va on va
la présenter le dossier est au mois de
septembre on a eu la grande joie et
bonheur d'apprendre que donc serment je
représente le jura pour la mission berne
et loto du patrimoine nous sommes le
représentant unique du jura il nous
manquait à peu près 60 euros pour
boucler le budget c'est ce qu'on a
demandé à la mission berne et ça nous a
été confirmée à peu près 15 jours c'est
tout frais donc 50 60 59 mille euros
exactement seront alloués pour boucler
l'ensemble des travaux par la mission
dernier la restauration de la fontaine
devrait s'achever au printemps elle
retrouvera alors tout le lustre imaginé
par son concepteur antoine louis attirer
anarchie texte de loi renommée
contemporain de claude nicolas ledoux